[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Musik]
cornelia breitschmid und schon maries
mutter wagen den großen schritt sie
wandern nach marokko aus
neues leben neues glück die familie
händler übernimmt den schwedisch
lappland eine hotel und campinganlage
und auf und davon in ein neues abenteuer
mit kamelen zieht die familie blum durch
das australische outback
[Musik]
diese villa ist bald das neue zuhause
von cornelia und jean-marie
ja
die russin 10 franken und wenn das alles
unter dem wasserspiegel für seine
kreationen
diese villa ist eigentlich nur der plan
b der beiden auswanderer ihre
ursprüngliche idee einer eigenen
feriensiedlung konnten sie nicht
verwirklichen
nun wollen sie hier in diesem haus gäste
beherbergen
fehlt nur noch der schlüssel aber von
den vielen anwesenden scheint in keiner
zu haben
hilf mir bitte ja wir schweizer wissen
wie man arbeitet
mexiko
[Musik]
tee trinken und abwarten
aber vom schlüssel keine spur
[Musik]
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
feierte die familie henzler mittsommer
mutter jasmin übernahm die meist die
ganze arbeit mit den kindern
trotz anfänglichen chaos mal
das fest ein voller erfolg
die marokkanische bürokratie zerstörte
den traum der eigenen feriensiedlung
aber nicht den traum der auswanderung
die aargauer mieteten kurzerhand eine
villa mit gästezimmern
für jean marie ist die garage das
wichtigste
unerwartete probleme gab es in
australien kurz vor der abreise wollten
die besitzer der kamele die tiere
plötzlich nicht mehr hergeben
doch in einer langen aussprache konnten
die blums missverständnisse aus dem weg
räumen
und ihre dreimonatige abenteuerreise
konnte endlich beginnen
[Musik]
cornelia und jean-marie warten noch
immer auf die schlüssel ihrer villa
[Musik]
schlüsselübergabe zehn anzeigen also den
hausschlüssel will ich dann an einen
ring machen und monika gärtner bitten
ihnen bringen
jetzt eine ganz groß raus
[Musik]
das einzige was die hand gewechselt hat
war das geld
[Musik]
ja ja ja alles gut
also mich hat das schon
toll ist die marokkanische kultur immer
wieder schwierig zu verstehen aber auch
hier gilt ein handeln ist ein handel die
aargauer erhalten die schlüssel am
nächsten tag wie abgemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit sechs wochen ist die familie blum
unterwegs
seit kurzem waren sie den ordner data
track entlang
das umfahren der väter ist für die
kamele ted und miss molly schon routine
geworden
doch das ort beck meinte es nicht nur
gut mit den abenteuern mit vier kanälen
sind sie aufgebrochen nur zwei sind
ihnen geblieben
euro
[Musik]
katzavs plätzchen unter dem bett ist
leer rhein ist jetzt der einzige
vierbeiner im hause henzler
bestimmt nicht haben sich gesehen zum
tierarzt gegangen
und dann ist es aber schon so wie das
leben funktioniert hat
noch nie
einer gedenktafel soll ewig an sie
erinnern schließlich hat die katze
geschichte geschrieben
mit einer auf dem beifahrersitz ist max
ausgewandert
[Musik]
bei ihrer ankunft springt die katze
schnurstracks auf diesen baum die
feuerwehr musste das tier runterholen
[Musik]
im outback wird es früher dunkel um 6
verschwindet die sonne hinter dem
horizont
die abenteurer suchen deshalb schon am
nachmittag einen ort für ihr nachtlager
geeignet ist ein platz erst wenn die
kamele da auch futter finden
blums hatten die einst wilden tiere mit
viel aufwand gezähmt umso mehr schmerzt
der unfall der sich in der zweiten woche
ihrer reise ereignet hatte
so behält sie sich losgelöst und und
wozu andere sind
harmonie
hat ihr nämlich einen hofstaat und dann
haben wir noch etwas musik das ist dann
guckt der vsg trainer vorerst bewegt ist
das ist es der ton alles einfach einfach
los
kamel da melina hatte den fuß gebrochen
und konnte nicht mehr weiter gehen
stundenlang haben wir ausprobiert und
ist entschieden hin zum
düsenjet am hätte dem messer auf das
trocknen forster wusste dass christopher
schmidt und machen das hängt sicher so
sein bereitwillig alle generationen
ihre schon vage blieben im schnitt mit
krone schlachten wo sie denn so
ich sehe noch
der welt
[Musik]
nicht ändern und dass sie danach das
plötzlich konnte sie selbst schiessen
ist
[Musik]
leider dort das sehe dass ich ja noch
linie sieht das sehr pragmatischer als
katholik sie aber für sie halt im himmel
ja es hat sich schon beschäftigt dass er
nach innen verarbeiten die blums
beschlossen mit zwei tieren
weiterzuziehen das dritte tier holte die
besitzerin zurück
entlang des uba data tracks liegt die
stillgelegte kann eisenbahnlinie und
wer hier die augen offen hält kann ganz
spezielle schätze finden
nicht so genau
[Musik]
eisen nägel für die kinder und brennholz
für den vater
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen sie wieder
ja
bis 21
[Musik]
schweizer rentner im marokkanischen
hinterland seit einigen wochen leben die
aargauer nun in ihren neuen daheim
[Applaus]
so marie suter fühlt sich wohl nur etwas
fehlt zum perfekten blick
[Musik]
cornelia breitschmid besorgt die
einkäufe zum heutigen schiri kommen lang
erwartete gäste
du hast oben gestellt
die schon mal wie gut
ihm geht es gut er musste zu hause
bleiben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
tabakpfeifen zu bauen ist das große
hobby von jean-marie seine dafür bestens
ausgestattet der werkstatt kommt heute
nach marokko
die werkstatt ist seit tagen unterwegs
sie wurde über das mittelmeer verschifft
und hat problemlos den zoll passiert
muss das rennen
ich bin beim verladen der bix ich weiß
nicht wie ich und und und 3 ich mich
lieber league will
die schwere maschine
muss ich eine definitiv eine stelle muss
ich den herren gehört man sich dann
nochmals verschieben aber die schwere
und das könne die analyten abladen und
so ich muss sagen dass sie das super
einer klage
gedroht roma crash
dann einfacher überzahl zu bauen
[Musik]
in der neuen heimat schweden hat der
ältere bub der henzlers heute seinen
ersten ins getan
[Musik]
im sogenannten kinderhaus von over tonio
ist der kindergarten und eine
kinderkrippe untergebracht
[Musik]
der jüngere sohn soll in einigen wochen
die kinderkrippe besuchen
[Gelächter]
ich brauchte es geschafft das ist gut
kinderbetreuung ist in schweden günstig
rund 160 franken im monat betragen die
krippen kosten
doch noch ist es zu früh für den kleinen
chemie glauben jasmin und max
mit ihrem jüngeren gehen sie sehr
behutsam um denn kaum war der kleine auf
der welt glaubten sie das kind schon
verloren zu haben nach einer langen und
komplizierten geburt liegt der kleine
unter schweren sauerstoffmangel
chemie war nahezu leblos um schäden am
gehirn zu vermeiden wo der chemie einer
speziellen kühl therapie unterzogen
und dann
vorsichtig wie man das
obwohl er weiß alles gute gilt ja als
und
[Musik]
mit so einem start im laden lecker hätte
ich nur noch mit humor nicht
der ältere ja ne ist groß genug und darf
bleiben
im orga früchte
[Musik]
endlich ist sie da john riise pfeifen
werkstatt
[Musik]
kommt schnell schauen
vielleicht das beste doch ihre ankunft
macht so marie nur noch nervöser
jetzt eine frage die schwere die schwere
maschine hast du sie im auto im auto nie
okay dann dann kannst du dann mit dem
auto so lange wie möglich war kein
problem dann schwer ist ja eigentlich
nicht weißt du ich bin ein alter mann
und er muss ja gar nicht tragen du musst
nur anschauen okay
[Applaus]
das ist
heftig
36 das ist schwer
hierhin an diese seite nicht
so fixiert
sind verrät
[Musik]
elektro machst du
da
will ich gar nicht ist gut es braucht
die schwere drechselbank ist nun an
ihren platz
[Musik]
dennoch muss sie aber ein paar teile
zusammensetzen
das kann mache dann habe ich schlafe
einem
bereich wo ist der leyen ruft uhr
aber das ist jetzt zwar schön die
richterin langsam
und gut das sieht doch gut aus
stolze 2000 franken liess sie schon
marie den transport seiner werkstatt
kosten jetzt kann er sich so richtig zu
hause fühlen
[Musik]
hast du freunde
und die leute sind alle nett also
wirklich ich habe noch nie irgendwie
probleme gehabt die leute sind immer so
nett wie man selber auch ist
vielen vielen dank irgendwie hört von
einer drauf war
das immer so dass du dich für nötig aber
das war es mir immer nachher wirklich es
ist doch vorher ist aber es gab einfach
nicht am tisch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die juli nächte in der australischen
wüste sind kalt das thermometer kann bis
zu zehn grad unter null senken wer als
erster auf steht macht
france vorbereiten
das ist
das
geradezu erschlagen hat darauf schaffte
und vorbereitet so macht
[Musik]
naja und amira genießen ein
unbezahlbares privileg die totale
freiheit rum zu toben so laut sie wollen
weit und breit keine nachbarn die sich
gestört fühlen könnten
es scheint dass diese weiter auf sabrina
entspannung und ruhe gibt
wer schon als kind ein so großes und
mächtiges tier und alleine führt tankt
wohl für das ganze leben eine gute
portion selbstvertrauen
sie fuhren mit ihr
die immer noch dass sie werden sie
werden dann halt was ich mache ist
bestritt wäre das
wirklich gerne und gut mit jedes mal hat
aber meistens
etwas davon haben
das jeden tag machen und doch ist sie
ihnen aber sie machen spaß machen
v
[Musik]
bei spielzeug
dadurch lösten wie war die nacht
geschlossen wir haben zwei junge
spielt
vorstoß werde den hatte ich mal eine
frage ja diese häuser sind das auch die
man sonst nicht in den einzelnen steht
diese kirche hat die hütten da das sind
tigers aber die duz und zu vermieten und
entließ ihn zu vermieten jaja aber gibt
auch nach dem anstrich und panahi möbel
und zum
glück ja
danke danke
aber wo kommen das beste tun als ihm
mercedes morgen unter leichter
denn auch hier im lot ist acht hektar
groß entsprechend viel platz haben hier
ideen und visionen
eines der projekte nimmt schon gestalt
an mitarbeitern aus dem dorf bauen die
henzlers eine riesige terrasse mit stieg
ich glaube das wird die größte terrasse
im dorf
wer hat schon eine 100 meter lange
terrasse
an die terrasse angegliedert ist die
küche für die campinggäste max möchte
darin eine bar eröffnen
hast du schon begonnen mit dem umbau
der barbetrieb muss aber zuerst von der
behörde bewilligt werden eine
gemeindeangestellte kommt zur inspektion
sowie sehen wir also wir stehen hier ist
dass die bar oder ist dass die küche für
die campinggäste
es wäre eben beides kann der raum als
küche und dafür genutzt werden
das ist schon möglich aber wenn die bahn
offen ist dann darf nicht gekocht werden
aber so schwierig ist es nicht max muss
lediglich einen zeitplan aufstellen wann
die küche von den camping gästen genutzt
werden darf
ich denke es wird kein problem sein
[Musik]
was schon
kraft war
immer wieder missverständnisse mit den
behörden immer wieder auf hilfe
angewiesen die aargauer wollen
selbstständiger werden
die beiden lernen arabisch
[Musik]
mit rollenspielen animiert die lehrerin
die schüler zum sprechen jean marie muss
bei einem mitschüler gemüse einkaufen
[Musik]
die
uschi frisch
schließlich
[Musik]
heißt auf arabisch
und das ist die liebe wird könig
duncan
schweden
am ersten tag viel aktiver als jean
marie aus wie sie dann auseinander
gesetzt haben hat sich schon mal wie
viel mehr eingebracht er ist also
genauso
[Musik]
früh 20 hat manche mängel projekt weil
damit der übersetzer ist es ja mit 20
schwierig
glauben und doch am abend können
cornelia und chambéry das gelernte
bereits anwenden
[Musik]
rush hour auf dem unna data trinkt
einer von ihnen
hat das relativ neue
lustige begegnungen das geht es ab
einzelne
weiß ich aber dass wir diesen stress
dasselbe das überhaupt das sehen wir die
zeit
mit zwei kamel stärken unterwegs legen
die blumes bloss 20 oder 30 kilometer am
tag zurück ihr treibstoff
abenteuerlust und natürlich wasser für
die tiere
sabrina hat einen schlauch entdeckt ist
er mit wasser gefüllt
nirgendwo
frau seine gefühle mit im schnitt ging
nicht
[Musik]
seit einigen tagen besuchte den
kindergarten und
noch ist johannes bester freund sei
nicht da
krimi
doch der abschied fällt dem kleinen
yanar diesmal schwer
[Musik]
ja
das leid ich konnte das nicht
jetzt muss kann
[Musik]
es
ist alles gut
[Musik]
das wäre doch schon sind die typischen
diesem grund
ist die
kinos gelockt
bereinigt kunstprojekt für uns
[Musik]
sagen immer die daumen kalorien ist
wichtig damit
das klingt auch spürte man die goldenen
dankt und alle sagen sie
nein das war nicht tiefgefroren
das kommt aus dem kühlschrank ist das
okay
im restaurant der campinganlage
verkaufen die schweizer auch essen zum
mitnehmen
aber es hat einfach nicht die
20 cent profitieren wir jetzt noch 14
kantonen so das ist utopie mehr stehen
diese gerade erst zwei aber durchsetzen
so
braucht mit kristen aber bringen mit dem
renovieren reparieren dann noch einmal
grenzen und dann fliegt er schon
ich brauche eine bar kennst du jemanden
kinder bauen ich kenne könne mädchen
hast du
kannst du eine stille
[Musik]
in der ferne hat markus eine farm
entdeckt
[Musik]
die farm oder was es auch immer einmal
war scheint komplett verwaist
[Musik]
war komisch
ist das tor nicht und
was
der besitzer der farm hat das wasser
nicht abgestellt reisende können sich
bedienen
take that sind
zurück das ist dann ist das problem
während des sommers ist es im norden von
schweden immerhin der helligkeit zum
trotz eine gute nacht geschichte gehört
dazu
[Musik]
wie sich jana und chemie ans neue daheim
gewöhnt haben schlafen sie noch bei den
eltern
[Musik]
lauf geschafft
aufgekommen
vater max geht trotz später stunde
nochmals arbeiten
trotz des innigen familien moment
eigentlich haben jasmin und max kaum
zeit füreinander
die gefahr besteht dass sie sich
verlieren könnten
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
die beziehung zwischen max und yasmin
ist dann zerbrechen
ich wohne hier mit print er wohnt
liebestöter
in marokko bauern die auswanderer ihre
gästehäuser um
hat es genug platz und für aufregung
sorgt die ankunft von enke lahm an
[Gelächter]
trotz schmerzen
genießt die familie blumen die letzten
wochen ihres abenteuer lebens
propst rink das was noch kommen
und sabrina und marcus sauer nochmals
zurück
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge